Terminus, je descends tout le monde.
Oh merci,
merci John Macmanaman.
Faisons l’amour, sans faire attention aux MST.
Et 4 fois.
Pas con.
"Oh putain j’ai chaud aux couilles."
Tu vois ça?
Ça, c’est un vrai badass.
Faudrait trop qu’on soit comme lui!
Ah
Je décroche.
Ben non.
Ben si, quand même.
-Non!
Prends ton courage à deux mains.
Voilà! Ça c’est badass!
Aïe …
Ah, c’était plus fort que ce que j’imaginais.
J’retire ma clé USB sans faire « éjecter»
BADASS!
J’mets une bouteille en verre dans la poubelle jaune
J’SUIS BADASS!
Si tu viens sur mon terter, j’te cache les feux verts
C’EST BADASS!
Et avec ceci, il vous faudra autre chose?
NON!
A une soirée déguisée, je viens pas déguisé
C’EST MORT!
Une pelouse interdite, sans vergogne je la piétine
J’SUIS BADASS!
J’like une photo sur facebook, je la dislike tout de suite!
BADASS!
A «1, 2, 3 soleil» j’me retourne au «2»
J’SUIS BADASS
Quand quelqu’un dit «chikachik», j’dis pas «aïe aïe aïe»
C’EST BADASS!
Bas les couilles des majuscules en début de phrase.
Quand j’achète un Tacotac, j’gratte «nul si découvert»
BADASS!
A la piscine, j’cours au bord du bassin
J’SUIS BADASS!
J’lance un bâton au chien mais en fait c’est une feinte
C’EST BADASS!
J’dépasse les lignes de confidentialité.
Tu vas faire quoi?
Vous êtes fiers de vous?
John Macmanaman!
Vous avez conscience que vous déshonorez totalement l’esprit Badass?
Ah bon?
Etre Badass, c’est pas seulement prendre une voix énervée.
C’est, une attitude.
Faire des trucs phénoménals.
Phénoménaux.
C’est bon, c’est compris?
Ne me décevez plus.
Quand je vais au Starbuck’s j’donne même pas mon vrai prénom!
BADASS!
J’clique sur «accepter» sans lire les conditions.
J’SUIS BADASS!
Si y’a un impact sur mon pare-brise je le répare pas
CARGLASS
Moi j’ai même pas peur de dire Voldemort
THUG LIFE
L’ouverture facile, je l’utilise pas
BADASS
Dans l’bus mon ticket je le valide pas
Quand le proviseur entre je me lève pas
BADASS
Quand quelqu’un éternue deux fois à la suite
je lui dis «à tes souhaits» et pas «à tes amours»
poto!
C’est qui le plus Badass?